most humans eat the same five to ten
meals ninety percent of the time if you
want to change the way you look you just
have to change those five to ten meals
that's it and so if you think about what
you had for breakfast every single day
this week and lunch every single day
this week and late night every single
day this week most of those times it's
only two or three things in each of
those little buckets that are actually
what you eat so it may sound super
overwhelmed like I have to start a diet
and I have to start counting calories
all you have to do is replace what those
five to ten meals are you can change the
way you look forever